another day another Trump double
standard involving what Russia does or
really what any other country does what
any country other than Russia does
towards the end of our New Year's break
Donald Trump accused China on Twitter of
allowing oil to go into North Korea
saying hey this is an impediment to
solving the North Korean problem
Trump's exact tweet said caught
red-handed very disappointed that China
is allowing oil to go into North Korea
there will never be a friendly solution
to the North Korea problem if this
continues to happen now before we get to
the hypocrisy I'll mention it's not
actually clear that China did what Trump
says they did we don't know at this
point whether China did or didn't allow
oil to go into North Korea what we do
know is that just two days later a
Russian tanker absolutely definitely
fueled up North Korean vessels as
reported by Reuters Rotert Reuters
reporting Russian tankers have supplied
fuel to North Korea on at least three
occasions in recent month by
transferring cargoes at sea according to
two senior Western European security
sources providing an economic lifeline
to the secretive communist state this is
a breach of sanctions Russia doing this
directly violate sanctions that are
currently in place but Donald Trump has
been completely silent on this and to be
clear I don't want to be accused of
hiding this if there's no evidence right
now that it was Russian state actors
that did this but rather these are
reports of individual individual Russian
actors choosing to do this but it still
violate sanctions and certainly the
Kremlin is well not necessarily behind
this or endorsing it they've done
nothing about it they've said nothing
about it so late let's break this down
sort of into its component pieces
whether or not this particular China
story is true Donald Trump is actually
correct to say and I've said this before
China is an impediment to solving the
North Korean problem there's no doubt
about it China could be part of a
solution but they're actually part of
the problem here the problem is that if
countries helping North Korea get in the
way of motivating them
to come to the table and maybe be a part
of constructive discussions
you've got to criticize Russia for it as
well but this has a further effect
obviously Trump is a hypocrite right and
it always happens to be hypocrisy about
not criticizing Russia it's never Chile
that has evaded Donald Trump's criticism
it's not Madagascar or Switzerland that
Trump could criticize but chooses not to
it's always Russia but the bigger impact
is that because Trump only slams China
and not Russia for effectively the same
thing it actually fuels the right wing
talking point of well why aren't we
better friends with Russia after all
they're not doing anything wrong well
they are they are doing things that
Trump is slamming other countries for
doing but his acolytes will never hear
about it because Trump doesn't mention
it when it comes to Russia Fox and
Friends doesn't mention it that means it
might as well not exist the president
Trump himself and that's the problem of
the echo chamber that I've been talking
about for years now and speaking of Fox
and Friends it might not be that Trump
is choosing not to slam Russia he
probably didn't know Russia did this
because Fox and Friends isn't talking
about it and he seems to get a lot of
his news from Fox and Friends
we know he gets his daily propaganda
file twice a day it's propaganda o'clock
where he's only told great things that
other media outlets are saying about him
so anyway it's very depressing but it
connects to this bigger picture I've
been talking about which is that we are
never going to convince the committed
trumpets that he is failing at his job
and with 50% voter turnout in the US and
a total lack of awareness from the
trumpets about what is even going on
I've run the numbers before Trump can
win with the 27% approval even less if
you fine-tune the math super
specifically that's why I'm worried
about 2018 because even with these very
low approval ratings that Donald Trump
has with the historically stunningly low
midterm election turnout rates Donald
Trump and Democrats can do really well
I'm sorry and Republicans can do really
well in 2018 and in 2020 even
these low approval ratings which is why
we all have to be activating around
getting out the vote and the midterms
and we will be doing exactly that you
can discuss this or any other story of
interest on our subreddit at david
pakman.com slash our EDD IT very close
to 5,000 subscribers on that subreddit
which I think will hit very very soon
thanks to many of you today's program is
brought to you in part by Skillshare it
is January you're probably starting to
think about really making good on those
New Year's resolutions some people
resolve to go to the gym I know my gym
is very very busy in January in February
some people say I'm gonna call mom more
often but our sponsor Skillshare is
encouraging you to learn a new skill in
2018 Skillshare is an online learning
platform with over 18,000 classes in
design business technology and more and
whether you're trying to deepen your
professional skill set or start some
kind of side business or just explore
something new Skillshare will keep you
learning in 2018 and beyond I actually
did a logo design course on Skillshare
and I am such a novice when it comes to
the creative arts I don't even know how
do you even start thinking generally
about the shape of a logo and it was a
really great class taught by an
excellent excellent teacher and just in
time for the new year skill share is
offering our listeners and viewers for a
limited time three months of skill share
for a 99 cents this is an absurdly good
deal to sign up go to Skillshare comm
forward slash Pakman 99 once again go to
Skillshare comm slash PA k MA and 99 to
get three months of skill share for only
99 cents act now for this special New
Year's offer and start learning a new
skill today